the FCC revoked a $900 million subsidy I
guess program from
starlink and you felt it was because why
yeah this is a pretty puzzling decision
to me that really can't be explained on
the law or the the facts are really
policy I think it can only be explained
when you step back and look at what you
know frankly it wasn't my term but the
Wall Street Journal uh called regulatory
harassment of Elon Musk and it cuts
across a wide range of administrative
agencies with the FCC in particular you
know we issued this award uh to starlink
back in 2020 almost a billion dollar to
to your point to subsidize to ensure
that 640,000 rural homes and businesses
would get covered with high-speed
internet 100 over 20 uh and what the FCC
did last week was in a three to2
decision so there's five Commissioners
I'm the senior Republican uh there's
three Democrats it was a Partyline vote
they decided to revoke that Award of one
nearly $1 billion and the reason they
said was because we don't think it's uh
reasonable or that starlink is
reasonably likely to be able to deliver
120 internet servers to those 640,000
locations there's a lot of problems with
that decision if you look at it you know
individually but I think the the the
strongest most compelling point is that
the federal government itself is relying
on starlink for very Mission critical
operations and connectivity the military
is entering into multi-million dollar
deals with starlink you know as we speak
and so plainly I think the technology in
the federal government's view is
reliable so what's going on here and my
theory of the case is that it goes back
to last year when President Biden uh was
in the White House and stood behind the
the podium with the official seal of the
president of the United States and said
that Elon Musk is worth being looked
into and a reporter followed up and said
how and President Biden said there's a
lot of ways uh and it's true there are a
lot of ways and since then this pace and
Cadence of again regulatory harassment
or inquiries looking into Elon Musk have
been rather unprecedent you've got the
FAA the nlrb the doj the Federal Trade
Commission the southern district of New
York the FAA and now the FCC joins in
the mix and so again I think any of
these individual decisions don't make a
lot of sense other than tying it back to
what President Biden said at the podium
because look administrative agencies um
you know they understand the cues that
are being sent from upon high and I
think that they read that that statement
from President Biden as a green light
now look there's way of looking at it
which is to say Elon Musk has a lot of
business operations so of course he's
going to run in with the government a
lot businesses that are on sort of the
the Leading Edge of a lot of these
industries therefore maybe you're going
to get extra scrutiny and I get that but
again if you look individually like the
nlrb basically went after them because
they insisted on having black t-shirts
at Tesla as opposed to allowing people
to wear uh t-shirts that would promote
unionization or you look at um the
Federal Trade Commission and they were
asking to get information about
reporters that were getting access to
information as part of the the Twitter
files reveal or the fish and wildlife
service which went after him because
there was a a handful of Bob White quail
eggs and some blue land crabs that got
charred uh after a SpaceX launch and so
when you look at these individually
again they don't seem to hold up other
than when you tie it back to that
broader position of the president so
let's just get to ground truth here uh
because politics has been inserted going
to get to ground truth as you've said
the government is buying star link it is
Mission critical I have starlink at both
of my homes here as you can see I'm at
my ski house and then at my other house
it frequently performs at the level of
my Broadband connectivity in other words
I'm able to tape this week in startups
and the all-in podcast over starlink and
in fact I have starlink because I need a
backup I'm a professional podcaster the
$1,200 I spend each year on starlink at
two different homes which is $2,400 if I
were to miss one episode of a podcast
you know it's thousands of dollars in
ads it easily justifies me having them
as just as backups but when I use them a
commissioner respectfully they hit the
10020 and people who are on boats who
are in remote areas are buying these
because it is the hands down best
solution for a rural or a non- landline
connection so what am I missing as a
consumer a dedicated consumer of
Starling and all the people who are
rural areas what are they missing and
the people on boats and planes and the
government what are we all missing about
10020 which we get from starlink and
we're over the moon about and people are
raving raving on social media when they
get on a plane with starlink I believe
there are a couple of airlines that have
it now that they cannot believe that the
Broadband Wireless Broadband is is good
what what are we all missing from our
firstperson realities yeah look again we
didn't have any Milestone or deadline
for starlink to kick in until 2025
that's when they were supposed to
provide service to at least 40% of that
640,000 location and yet the fcc's
decision said we don't think it's likely
that they're going to get there uh by
2025 which again doesn't make sense when
you look at people's individual
experiences what they pointed to
specifically was there was some Uka
Nationwide speed test average data that
was showing speeds below 120 but again
didn't need to hit 120 until 2025 and
moreover the Uka data was you know
averaged Nationwide it wasn't about you
know how they directing beams to these
particular communities and the other
thing to think about is you know
competitively as well so we ran this
what we call a reverse auction which
means in in 2020 we said we're setting
aside N9 billion dollar and we're going
to try to connect something like eight
million uh homes in businesses that were
on the wrong side the just provide to
highspeed connectivity for the first
time and we let a range of different
Technologies compete and it was
controversial at the time that we even
let starlink and there's other low worth
orbit satellite systems that are going
up right now Amazon's skyper is one
that's getting up and off the ground now
as well and so we bid it out and
starlink won in these areas but other
providers won in other areas there were
something like 180 different winners uh
some Fiber some fixed Wireless so
there's a lot of different technologies
that won but again you know we really
sort of created an entirely new standard
and applied it only to one of those 180
winners which was starling and said look
since you're not doing 120 today uh
we're not you know reasonably confident
that you're going to do it in the future
and again it was a backwards decision
too because they looked at the the
Starship um the Starship launches and
they said well those have been failures
and I'm thinking to myself you know we
made fun of trade press that thought
that those were failures when you don't
understand how technology works so again
to say we're looking at these two data
points these two ukas spe test data
points and we're g to somehow draw a
straight line between them and say look
you know we don't think you're going to
get to 120 that's not how technology
develops it's a hockey curve that saw
tooths along the way and so I think it
was a really sort of backwards looking
decision from the FCC from a from just
an understanding of Technology
perspective too listen selling software
is hard enough right now man it's hand
toand combat out there in B2B land the
last thing you need to do is slow your
sales team down because you don't have
your sock 2 dialed in so if you're SAS
or a services company and you store
consumer data in the cloud you know what
you need to do you need to check out
vanta they're going to get your sock to
compliant easier and faster and vanta
makes it so easy to get and renew your
sock 2 on average vanta customers are
sock to comply in Just 2 to 4 weeks
compare that to 3 to 5 months without
vanta they're going to save you hundreds
of hours of work and up to 85% on
compliance cost and vanta does more than
just sock 2 they also automate up to 90%
compliance for gdpr Hippa and more you
can't afford to lose out on those major
customers the lighthouse customers the
big fish the whales because of silly
stuff like locking compliance just work
with vanta I'm an investor in the
company it's a great company get your
compliance automated get it tight tight
is right and close those big deals
here's the best part Van's going to give
you a thousand off because they love
this weekend startups they love startups
v.com twist that's V n.com twist to get
$1,000 off your stock too